نذهب الان الى جدل دراما ووقفتنا اليوميه
مع الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي من القاهره
ينضم الينا اذا الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي
اهلا بك سيد طارق من جديد معنا في رمضان
اهلا بكم طيب اهلا بك طيب نبدا بموضوع
متكرر مع الاعمال الدراميه الرمضانيه هذا
الشهر الفنانه غاده عبد الرازق وفريق عمل
مسلسل ثلثه يواجه دعوه قضائيه بتهمه
التعدي على حقوق الملكيه الفكريه لقصه
المسلسل طبعا الموضوع تكرر مع دنيا سمير
غانم في مسلسل جات سليمه صح
مضبوط
وسيتكرر مع اعمال اخرى
الحياه فكره تشابه الاعمال الدراميه
وارده جدا لكن القانون كمان صريح يعني في
فكره عامه يعني زي مثلا الانتقام ما هو
معمول اكتر من المسلسل من اللي احنا
بنتفرج عليهم في رمضان هل كلهم مقتبسين من
بعض او سرقوا من بعض لا القانون يقول ايه
باللغه العربيه كده وهو بيطبق وضع الحافر
على الحافر يعني التطابق الشديد
وده اتصور في بعض التيمات العامه ما يبقاش
فيها هذا التطابق وبالتالي غالبا مثل هذه
القضايا اللي هي فيها تهام بالسرقه بتسقط
في محكمه اول درجه لانها مش متوفره فيها
الشروط الموسيقى مثلا لازم يبقى فيه اربع
موازير متتابعه اذا ما فيش اربعه متتابعين
ما تبقاش سرقه يعني كل حاجه لها قواعد
مش مجرد تشابه لا لازم تطابق التطابق وليس
التشابك قد يكون هناك تشابه لكن بيزل
التطابق هو الفيصل بس حتى في مساله اللهجه
والدور لانه في موضوع اخر شائك تحدثنا
يعني بالامس عن الاستعانه مخرجين سوريين
في دراما التاريخيه اليوم الممثل المصري
احمد ماهر يفتح النار عن نجم السوري جمال
سليمان ويقول له انه انه اولى بالادوار
الصاعديه
فما الذي يدفع برايكم ممثل كبير مثل احمد
ماهر لذلك ولهكذا تصريحات
الحاله لم تكن للمره الاولى انا متذكر
جيدا سنه 2008 او 2007 كان في اول مسلسل
يظهر في جمال سليمان وهو حدائق الشيطان
برضو احمد ماهر وهو فنان كبير زي ما حضرتك
قلت بالظبط احد الفنانين الكبار فتح النار
وقال انا اولى انا مصري وانا صعيدي وانا
اجيد اكتر منه ورد عليه اسماعيل عبد
الحافظ وده مخرج المسلسل انا شيطان قال
انه في اعتبارات كثيره جدا في الاختيار
احمد ماهر ممثل طبعا مهم لكن اللجوميه
حاجه ثانيه ربما هو بيفتقد النجوميه لتجعل
المخرج يدي له ادوار كبيره يعني ادوار
رئيسيه او ادوار بطوله هو ده يمكن المازق
اللي عند احمد ماهر وعشان كده لم تكن
للمره الاولى وبعدين انا ضد فكره ان حد
مصري او حد سوري او حد خليجي يقول انا
اولى لا في الفن ما فيش اولى الفن الاوفق
هو اللي يشتغل ممكن واحد مصري يعمل يعمل
دور باللهجه الخليجيه ويتقنها ما ينفعش حد
يقول اشمعنا او واحد لبناني يعمل باللهجه
المصريه ويتقنها ما ينفعش واحد مصري يقول
اشمعنا وهكذا انا ضد الحقيقه
السلاح ده انك تطعم الاخر لمجرد ان هو مش
ابن البلد دي لا العالم العربي المفروض
انه يتجاوز ده والفن يتجاوز كل ده ومصر
تحديدا اللي هي المفروض بتفتح الباب لكل
العرب المفروض تتجاوز تماما الحته دي مع
كل حب لاحمد ماهر انا عارف حتى بالحياه يا
استاذ طارق الموهبه لا علاقه لها لا
بالاقدميه ولا بجنسيه ولا هي موهبه ولا
بالجنسيه صح ونحن نتشكره جدا ومنشوفك على
خير ان شاء الله